what is it real alpha-male well actually
I don't like that name alpha-male
because so many people don't understand
the true meaning of what it means to be
an alpha male you know who I'm talking
about you've met them
there's self-proclaimed self-professed
alpha males that are not really alpha
males but just arrogant fools should I
say dumb bullies so what is a real alpha
male well let's get into the video
[Music]
mistakes mistakes make you stronger so
I've seen a lot of talk on alpha males
in the comments and a lot of different
videos and also just on social media and
the things that I've read is just
mind-blowing so what is a real alpha
male is it a guy that bullies those
around him to get what he wants he's
either guy that's big and strong and
laughs and breaks down those who are
weaker than him or is he the one that
tries to show off and impress other
people by doing stupid things no a real
alpha male is a great leader it's
somebody that really cares about other
people we're not animals we're humans
so what makes a alpha male a great
leader well let's start with the first
characteristic
[Music]
honesty and integrity people only really
follow a leader if he shows that he can
be trusted
this means that a real alpha male will
act on his values instead of his
personal gain
he inspires others he doesn't break him
down emotionally or psychologically or
physically it's a lot of guys out there
to think if they act aggressively and
arrogant and breaking people down that
they are alpha male but if you live this
way she look behind you because you'll
realize that there's nobody following
you because nobody likes to follow
arrogant self-absorbed fool a real alpha
male inspires others to dream more learn
more do more and become more they unlock
people's potential to become better
accountability a real alpha male knows
that leadership is a lot more than just
about power it's about vision and
accountability he accepts responsibility
for his actions and he owns his mistakes
why's he sees the bigger picture and he
understand that is more important to
become a man of value compared to a man
of success this is actually one of the
smartest things Albert Einstein said
he has commitment and passion he doesn't
feel commitment because the only thing
he fears is wasting his time and he
moves forward with great passion because
he knows that great men are men who was
forward with real passion
[Music]
they have charisma fake alpha males they
don't have charisma they just dump
bullies that nobody likes
simply put people are more likely to
follow the lead of somebody that they
like the best leaders are well-spoken
friendly and approachable they are this
way not because it's an act but because
they really genuinely care about people
decisiveness real alpha-male is capable
of making good decisions because they
know if things are not gonna work out
great they'll need to hold themselves
accountable and they accept the risks
many people cannot do that empowerment
he does not bully others to force them
to do his bidding no leader has become
great leaders not because of their power
but because they have the ability to
empower other people to become great
themselves confidence
the alpha male doesn't try to improve
his position by talking big about
himself of puffing himself up in front
of other people only insecure people do
that the real alpha male is self-aware
and content with himself he's confident
in himself because he knows his
strengths and weaknesses greatly there's
not that they don't need to try and act
tough like fake alpha males because they
know that their confidence and humility
underscores their toughness
empathy if you don't have empathy you
can never become a great leader
why because understanding the problems
of other people and and also feeling
their pain is the first step to become a
great leader and if people see that they
will gladly follow him now just a bonus
tip and this is very important so listen
up
[Music]
fake alpha males cannot control their
emotions great leaders they learn how to
control not only their emotions but also
their thoughts because they know that
other control thoughts or emotions makes
smart men stupid
[Music]